hi my name is Kristen Pascal from
Wolfram research South America today I
am presenting surfing the blockchains
light Korean experience stay tuned
thank you very much for coming so before
starting I have to tell you that if you
went to interact with some part of my
presentation you want to have a cure
code scanner on your cell phone so I'll
give you a minute to download it so the
mean time so everyone has like a nice
template they don't have that so I'm
just writing my name there kristin
pascal from Wolfram research South
America our team is mainly based in Lima
Peru so well do you download your app so
today I'm going to present you some cool
stuff we do with blockchain in our
technology and I'll show you who is
responsible for all these so we have in
the blogging team we have yellow Edison
and Daniel we also have the integrated
services team
Erasmo and one we also have our
cryptography wizards
so that's Daria and Konstantin also so
we wouldn't be able to do anything
without our lovely assistant project
manager Carlos and Donna and of course
our manager Johan who is going to give a
presentation after this one so stay in
the room it's going to be mind-blowing
and he doesn't like pictures and I
totally respect that so I got for him
they only I'm the best Leo Messi yeah
all right so are you ready let's start
with this all right so we'll start with
some general information about
blockchain so we try to make our
functions with an intuitive enough so
you can understand from the name what
you are doing so let's do something like
these blockchain launching data let's
point this to the Bitcoin blockchain and
here you'll be able to see some current
information of the Bitcoin network see
like the like the Korean number of
blocks the latest cash
we have something very cool that not
every everyone has which is the
connection to the test Nate Nate work
how this works
all right and so I can do the same thing
with aetherium so according to the
weather only supporting aetherium and
Bitcoin but we're working on supporting
more more blockchain so it's to warm up
let's play a little bit with these data
here so we try to provide all these has
computational data so I know let's make
some cool lease plot with this
so let's look up here let's take the
lowest gas price and these are just some
useful if Hyrum stats and this is just a
very very basic example so but it is you
can all use you you can use all these
data to to do like cool stuff so for
example here I have very simple lease
plot of all visa stats all right so
let's go a little bit deeper and let's
explore the blocks so I have the
blockchain block function block should
block data function which is going to
get information about that specific blog
in this case I'm going to get the latest
block of the Bitcoin blockchain let me
present this as a data set here all
right so here you have basically all the
information you you're getting a block
header and and more so you have liked
address the transaction lease the time
when these block was mine let's try the
same with aetherium let me change these
you should work alright so we can do the
same with with both Bitcoin and and if
you room so one very cool thing about
the Wolfram language is that it knows
about the about the real world so let's
say I'm going to get the byte count so
the bike can be basically the size of
the of the block so these are bytes and
I can use the quantity function to
assign units to these so these are bytes
so if I do it now like a unit convert of
these and let's say well the megabytes I
should now get the result in in
megabytes all right so let's play a
little bit more with this so I have this
functional plan to submit to the
function repository Bob sign hurry show
that yesterday all right so let's try
with the between block and in the theory
block so this is just like a beautiful
comparison so you can actually the
easy-like is small red dot here let's
just get in our luck miss do we look
it's going to look better well it's
super small I should let's try this with
the with a bit contested that one has
smaller blocks so let's try these
blockchain base goes G we're gonna do
Bitcoin that's net here let's extract
the byte count
so I'm comparing the sizes between the
theorem and and in a Bitcoin block so
the red one here is a theorem one all
right so let's go even deeper and let's
blow some transactions so we had these
Bitcoin block here that has a
transaction list right so what I'm doing
I'm doing here I'm going to remove the
coinbase transaction and then I'm gonna
do a random choice so we get any random
transaction from here
what's a transaction ID let me save
these as inference section.80
all right and this to you about
intersection so we have the blockchain
transaction data which you may guess is
to extract data from the transaction
unless stick right now to the with a
Bitcoin blockchain so the blockchain
base option and the dollar blockchain
base variable it's very similar to the
cloud base if you are familiar with
those functions you're but you probably
understand how this works right so let's
strike all right so I get a lot of
information from from this transaction
here so let's explore let's say the
outputs the outputs are interesting
because you can see here for example
here we have AI standard paid to public
key hash scrape here I see one peytie
script a script so we are working on
getting all the information we can from
the from the block chains and not only
that and this is like super super useful
for educational purposes because we even
use our own technology to learn about
this blockchain so we are working in a
team or blockchains to our language and
like the development cycle starts with
learning and researching about these
block chains so we're probably not going
to have this in the next release but
probably an 11
I mean 12.1 we are working on on a big
constraint interpreter so you be able to
run this code in the world from language
and get a symbolic representation of all
these alright so under equal T and so I
was telling you before about how we how
the world from language knows about the
real world so remember we had less booty
so data set so let's say this
transaction here has these total
bitcoins worth transacted here so let's
extract these this and the Wolfram
language knows was the full form of
these the Wolfram language knows that
these are bitcoins so I can do something
like like currency convert of these
bitcoins to you let's say US dollars so
I should get the actual value in US
dollars we have another another property
that is called the feet that's it
including in the transaction to to be
aware that reminders so let's drive here
with a fee and a more exotic currency
like Peruvian so lists all right you get
some cookies with that in Peru and we
can even the currency camber between
cryptocurrencies so I hope this works
we're going to convert this into ripples
yeah so here's that that's amazing
alright so let's do some fun stuff here
I recently learn about the been force
law do you know what's the verb for
o'clock
well if you don't know I'm gonna show
you a very very cool function my group
developed this called Wikipedia data
let's try so with Wikipedia data you can
extract information from from the
Wikipedia article so Benford's law is is
a distribution also called the first
digit law
where when you take the leading digit so
that the first deed of real life data
sets usually find that the number one
appears about thirty percent of the time
number nine appears about five percent
of the time and you can find this in in
different data sets like like
electricity bills
stock prices house prices population and
that's another opportunity to show you
another amazing function we developed
with my group it's called what image
search so I'll show you how been ports
Lord how the distribution looked like
alright so it looks something like this
so let's do a simple experiment let's
see a a transaction if all the
transaction in in a block followed this
distribution so we have the transaction
list here these law words for all bases
I'm going to use decimal base here
because it's it's easier so you can't
you convert all these into decimal sorry
these are this here are our hex numbers
alright so I'm going to convert all
these into decimal and extract the
integer digits all right and now I'm
going to get just the first numbers and
create a histogram well this is just one
block what about if we let's do
something let's create a function that
receives a blocks in argument and here
we can do blockchain block data block
let's the blockchain base goes to
Bitcoin thinks I'm the only thing we
need so let's try this so have your
phones ready because interaction is
coming all right let's try this so
just any blood so what I'm doing and
doing here now is I'm going to create a
form page that receives a block they're
going to be an integer here and that's
going to use our block variable and I'm
going to cloud deploy this to our cloud
let's call this well and add permissions
public so anyone can use it here all
right so let me make a barcode image of
this so if you scan these can you scan
this alright so you should get and
actually so I think that one we have a
nerd talk about will run on the mall on
in the mobile world with Bart she'll
probably show you more cool stuff but
this digital world on your on your
mobile phone so just play with any block
and and you should see if if it follows
this distribution so if you want to scan
these a minute there alright let's talk
now about API so I'm going to use this
code here so I think one of the most
powerful functions we have is the API
function that that allows us to expose
all these power of their world from
language to to the world so let's make a
very simple API here let's do something
like this so I'm going to use the
blockchain block function to to get
let's say the size of the block that's a
byte count I'm going to
turn this into a string so I add here
something like the size of these block
is this and put bytes here smiley face
is called these API test alright so I
just created an API so if I go for
example to my terminal here so know that
I'm not longer using Wolfram language
I'm using a regular bus terminal so
let's try if I do blog 1 2 3 4 5 6
yeah I got a result here so let's live
dangerously and try to break these so
that's yet another opportunity to show
you an amazing function my grow develop
called text translation so let's say
we're gonna make these API return the
result in Italian let me deploy this
again and now let's go to shall let's
try this from Python alright so let's
try again we I don't know any block all
right and let's print here the contents
yeah I got versatile in Italian here
it's amazing
all right oh thank you
so let's play little B with cryptography
alright so we have a very cool function
to generate a symmetric Keepers so I'm
going to make one using the elliptical
vidcon uses right so I have now a
private key and a pot and a public key
so let's try here let's get the poly key
and if you are familiar with Bitcoin you
probably know about the what what's a
bitcoin address so I'm going to generate
beacon address using these public keys
I'm gonna do here a blockchain besos G
Bitcoin also if you are familiar with
with a designate you will see if I use
the testement here I get an address with
the structure you find intestine it okay
so I'm gonna save the address here
that's numbers only do all right I have
an address here I'm going to create a
barcode image which of these so that's
the address secure code and I'm going to
show you yet another amazing function my
teen developed called send message so
I'm going to send these QR code to my
cell phone
well I hope this works
alright so if I do this and if I go to
my cell phone here should get the result
yeah here it's amazing
our
so just one more thing and like to call
this the bondage drug because if it
works is going to be an actual track so
we had these so we headed the blog here
right we had a drone section list right
so we're going to do something crazy
here so let's take all these transaction
IDs and let's convert them so let's get
the ASCII code of each of each
characters I'm gonna do character code
all right and from here let's just take
was flat in this list first alright
let's take just I don't know 100 of this
then we join this down a little bit and
alright so I I got the ASCII codes and
I'm gonna play with these so I'm going
to create a sound node with each of
these so let's get the sound out here
played a little bit with the temp
another crazy instrument right so if
this works I should get a sound object
naturally I just learned that thanks to
you
shoddy is amazing team we can do very
cool stuff without it so let's tries to
I just learn about the audio bit shift
function so let's shift this to this
let's add some reverb maybe the reverb
let's use the small hole fact and
finally now do delay alright well since
it's work
so well I've never had a chance before
to dedicate a song to anyone like on
stage so I'm taking the chance I'm going
to dedicate this song to my good friend
Judy Willis and Reena who is in the
audience right now all right so let's
hear how a Bitcoin block sounds like
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright so I'm gonna share with with you
guys and you can play this you can play
with these on your phone
I hope this words is probably going to
break a lot with some with some blogs
and but anyway so I'm going to cloudy
ploidies and this will actually work
from the front your mobile phone when we
call these sounds add permissions it's
public all right well let me know if
this works
so just candies here well play with that
I will try with lots over 300,000 yes
this
all right yeah and you can also like
follow me on Instagram and Twitter you
seen this handle and well we had fun
thank you
[Applause]